like a boss
[inaudible]
it's like halfway through this season,
six of a 77 sunset strip.
Um,
and evidently see,
as I said,
season six,
you gotta watch it.
It's on at 4:00 AM on Btby.
Just take the fucking thing.
I want to get more people to watch it because I'm worried because I found out
that they started broadcasting all the episodes back in November and I missed
the first five seasons and we're getting towards the end here of season six
because they didn't do a full season.
They got canceled like three quarters of the way through.
Um,
and I'd like to see the original ones because I'd like to see what La look back
then.
You know,
hopefully they do some exterior's,
although I know most of it was formed on the backlot filmed on the backlog in
Warner brothers.
Um,
but uh,
I'm loving this season,
so I'm worried that the other one's going to be a little hokey cause I guess a
lot of people didn't like seasoned six.
First of all,
they fired the whole fucking cast as I butchered.
Sorry.
Um,
but I also didn't realize that they made Efram Zimbalist juniors character a lot
more surly and uh,
but I'm loving them.
So now I'm worried that I saw season six first.
And if I go back and look at the others,
I'm not going to like the show the same with the other people cause I get you
just get used to how the guy behaves,
you know.
But some of the lines,
man,
some of the shit that people say on that
blessing in disguise.
This is a big hotel in Facebook.
Know what's wrong.
I don't lie.
I thought maybe you'd know the truth when you heard it.
Man Once told me he didn't have a gun.
It was the truth.
I think I should've asked him if he had a knife.
[inaudible] was so happy.
Yes sir.
Seven 85
here's some things in like,
you know,
women are,
are,
are talking about how guys behave around them.
You know,
like in some of the shit that they say,
it's like Jesus Christ.
I mean,
I'm sure that guy is out there,
but what the fuck,
you know,
since season six of psalm 77 sunset strip,
they sounds like what some of these women and describing in some of the shit I
heard them say,
guys saying to women on that show pipe down,
shut up.
Not to mention F F from tries to bang his fucking secretary.
Sure.
After we finished,
we here
tried to look up her dress one ups.
I'm just sitting there on this guy would get me Tude so fucking fast and have
his full head of hair spinning.
Right.
And then my favorite one ever faber one ever is that mentioned on another
podcast is when he sat down in um,
this episode with the actor that ended up playing the professor or Gilligan's
island.
Sorry,
I'm talking through yawns right now.
Why don't you to see you let them out of that cage that at least we'll keep the
vampires.
I mean the bats from becoming a nuisance.
It's a good idea,
professor.
Come on,
let's go shouting it.
Wait a minute.
You better get the girls to put a dressing on that moon right now.
Hey,
I better do it right now because I try to come up with empire.
They don't even look at me.
Oh,
I don't want you with the skipper ever mentioning this vampire business again.
There's no sense that upsetting togethers over anything so preposterous.
Agreed.
The accident played the professor in Gilligan's island and need,
the guy was three drinks in
and firms meeting them.
It's the middle of the day and the guy orders his fourth drink
and a informal goes.
You've got a pretty active eligible for lunchtime.
You on the sauce.
Oh.
What do you think
before you got to slow down and go to the store from here,
you wind up trying to sell toy elephants at Democrats.
Is that all you got to say?
Take a deep breath and let's come out of the starting gate together.
I've already told you,
is there anything you want to change?
I don't know what you mean by that.
I mean you've got a pretty active elbow for lunchtime.
Are you on the juice?
No alcohol.
He had a headache.
I saw her,
at least I was sure that I did know.
I don't know.
I don't know what to think.
That is the one thing also that I love about that show.
It makes you feel better about drinking and smoking cause uh,
that from Zimbalist almost made 90.
Okay.
And there's barely a scene.
He's not smoking a cigarette and he's really smoking it too.
And that's just on the tape that they use.
So who knows?
Um,
all right.
With that,
should I read a little bit of advertising?
Yeah.
Why don't I do that?
No pressure yet.
We can lift the egg
and the bandaid.
Plastic Strip never comes loop.
Maybe you don't want to boil eggs this way,
that you do want the extra protection of bandaid plastic strip.
They take better care of little customs scratching.
They stay put.